Aaron Sampson here with jeff strain
founder of undead labs I'm here to take
a look at Stan decayed your one survival
edition all right so state of decay I
beat it I beat it on PC very old Xbox
360 what do you guys bringing with the
year when survival edition that'll get
players coming back to table well a
couple things
first of all the game has been
remastered in 1080p which means that
most of the in-game textures have been
touched and we offered we've
substantially polished up and remastered
the animations as well and and we've
gone through and just smoothed out a lot
of the rough edges a lot of the user
interface is refined for both efficiency
and accountability a lot of the just
kind of combat mechanics have been
refined there's a new unarmed combat
mode overall it's you know our goal is
to just make this the definitive state
of decay experience and take advantage
of the new hardware we have on xbox want
to be able to do that and you will find
because the Xbox one is faster hardware
and we're able to draw faster we can now
increase the speed of the vehicle so
that you get more of a feeling of being
in a sports car you're basically gonna
make me more dangerous to myself I am
gonna make you more dangerous to
yourself cuz I remember drive it around
this game in a muscle car feeling great
for about an hour and whoops I flipped
it and when Amy was Amba Gordon Massa
Cary yeah yeah exactly we want to do
more of them and so we have taken the
opportunity to add tons of new vehicles
this is one of them a lot of them are
kind of more fun takes on vehicles than
a lot of the more kind of baseline cars
we had in the first new weapons there is
a new playable character which I believe
you can see right here she is
available as a special unlock for
customers of the game who played on xbox
or pc the first round and they will get
a unique code to be able to unlock her
for a year one survival edition she
comes with some unique items and weapons
that only she has access to and some
other kind of surprises that players
will experience when they play is her
can she die like other characters in the
game
absolutely it wouldn't be a state of
decay game if you couldn't die so the
year 1 survival edition comes with the
core game comes with lifeline yeah we're
bundling the original game along with
the lifeline and breakdown add-ons like
I said our goal is to make this the
definitive state of decay experience so
both of those add-ons really expanded
the game in unique ways breakdown took
the the simulation of the original game
and kind of turn that into a how long
can you survive type of mechanism where
it's just more of a pure sandbox
environment whereas lifeline went the
opposite route and made it more of a
directed narrative experience you're
part of a the last remnants of the US
military trying to get high impact or
very important NPCs out of the area
doctors and scientists and people who
the government thinks can can help
figure out what's going on or is that
kind of state of decay in Reverse right
instead of starting as a survivor
building your arsenal you started as a
soldier with a heavy arsenal and slowly
got whittled down over time that's right
zombie apocalypse and you can really
look at lifeline and breakdown as kind
of end points along a spectrum with the
original game somewhere in the middle
and that's what we want to do with with
this this game we really love the
simulation aspects we really love the
kind of open-world sandbox but there has
to be context there has to be meaning so
the story that we inject into it is just
enough to kind of keep you understanding
what your place in the world is and what
you're trying to accomplish and a
vehicle to introduce unique and
interesting characters into the mix as
well there are new characters that
you'll meet here in
one scrabble edition and one of the
things that we've done is take a lot of
those really compelling and interesting
characters from lifeline like lieutenant
Kelly Etheridge and make them playable
characters here in break down so that
you have the opportunity to play as
those people as well
now you also said you tweak the
interface a little bit I remember the
first time I played state of decay it
was like a third-person action game for
the first like two hours and then I
realized I was doing it completely wrong
that's right I was actually supposed to
be playing more of a sim like take care
of all of my people kind of game that's
right what have you guys done to the
interface to help people kind of ease
into the transition between the first
person they play with and the whole camp
that they'd then have to you know help
after that and the first thing we did
was we pushed a lot of the role-playing
attributes of your character onto that
first page of the UI so when you first
open it up you're going to see
everything about your character and we
used to actually mix in a lot of other
things on this first page from your
community so it wasn't really clear what
you were looking at but now it's very
clear when you open this up this is me
this is my inventory and these are my
attributes that I can level over time
make that very clear and then on the
following tab we group everything you
need to manage your community including
who your fellow survivors are what their
status is whether they're away or at
home whether they're sick with how much
they trust you and then we we put of
course all your base management things
because that's the thing you you
discover last and that you really need
to master last but a lot of us just kind
of the flow of the interface the
discoverability the interface and kind
of making sure that it works intuitively
we really did a lot of usability testing
and kind of looked at where people were
getting tripped up on that and we're
able to go make some some pretty
substantial enhancements to that who is
stealing all the stuff in the locker
exactly right
this is a
our new vehicle players of the original
that may remember little piggy towing
down in the city of Marshall there was a
billboard and a junkyard and the truck
was up on the Billboard and everybody
always looked up at that and wished man
it'd be awesome if I could drive that
truck well here it is
you can now drive it and there's lots of
little surprises like this sprinkled
throughout the game for players of the
original is well seems like you're
taking a little bit more whimsical
approach to it I you know I think there
is you know
state of decay is a it's a core game for
core gamers it's it's it's hard right
mean it's a it's a sophisticated game
there's a lot to learn and it's
rewarding in that depth but it's it's
not for kind of somebody looking for a
solitaire experience and you know what
we wanted to do was was have a little
bit of fun reward the players that had
been with us from the beginning add a
few more these whimsical elements that
cause you to laugh and smile but still
retain that core of this is a survival
simulation other things we brought in we
had Jesper Kyd the composer who did all
the music for the state of decay series
come back to 30 minutes more of original
music for this we have new kind of
threat mechanics that ramp the music up
as your threat increases so it's it's
not only just pleasant to listen to but
it also gives you a play cue to know hey
zombies have spot of me or maybe there's
a lot of them in the area or maybe I'm
getting weak and I need to go home and
rest and switch out for another
character the music helps you understand
that now and helps convey that to you so
you know have to ask the question
community's most requested was still
co-op I think this cute this game
screamed for it yeah where you guys add
on co-op so this game is like I said the
definitive edition of the original game
this game is a single-player again
probably a single-player game but we've
also said and we still stand by this
that
the future you know the multiplayers at
the heart of the future of stated okay
and we have a as we announced earlier
last year a long-term partnership with
Microsoft to continue to work within
this IP and you can be assured the
multiplayer is at the center of our
minds yeah for whatever comes next
awesome well thank you for talking to us
about save decay your one survival
edition can you let the folks at home
know when this commute up and what
platforms yep you will be able to play
state educator one survival edition on
April 28 and the price is $29.99 US and
euro and $19.99 great British pounds
existing customers who bought it for
Xbox 360 or or on Steam will get a 33
percent discount on that and access to
the special character here that's just
for them that is Xbox one and PC Stan
thank you so much all right thank you
appreciate it
you